the Catalan wholesale charges for voice  calls in the EU under a deal struck  between Parliament negotiators and  member states from June fifteenth  Europeans traveling abroad can use their  phones without extra charges a number of  countries targeted by the US travel ban  signed by president Trump EU lawmakers  denounced the measure which they say  goes against core values the Erasmus  student exchange program is 30 years old  with Erasmus plus any Peas want to  extend it to benefit all young people  not just University students there are  as many legal systems for child adoption  as there are in you countries any Peas  want to close loopholes to protect  children and their parents across the EU  the amount of CI that disappeared in the  last 35 Arctic summers any PS are  worried that big melts will damage the  planets ecosystem  [Music]